[Música]
y hoy en este directo a volvemos hasta
Ecuador donde hoy ya sí que dio comienzo
en la asamblea nacional el juicio
político contra el presidente Guillermo
lasso acusado de presunto peculado por
la oposición que cuenta con mayoría en
el congreso según la acusación lasso
permitió que continuara en contratos de
la empresa Estatal flota petrolera
ecuatoriana con presuntas
irregularidades el presidente se
defiende alegando que los contratos
venían del anterior ejecutivo y que el
proceso que se ha creado en su contra es
ficticio para ampliar conectamos con
nuestro corresponsal Gustavo Ortega
Gustavo ha habido fuertes acusaciones
cruzadas hoy en esta primera jornada ha
aportado algo la oposición ha aportado
pruebas sobre sus acusaciones Y qué ha
dicho el presidente
Sí muy buenas noches Rodrigo fuertes
acusaciones entre parte y parte Durante
este desarrollo de juicio político en
contra del presidente de la república
por el supuesto delito de peculado tal y
como tú lo has dicho fuerte esa
acusaciones Pero qué se ha dicho el día
de hoy Bueno una de sus interpelantes el
Viviana veloz quien ha sido la líder de
esta acusación en contra del presidente
de la república ha resaltado sobre los
sobreprecios de los alquileres de Los
buques para transporte de crudo ha
hablado también sobre los sobreprecios
de las comisiones de los Brokers para la
gestión de estos contratos entre la
estatal flopep y en la privada amazonas
tanker pool la cual habría ocasionado
perjuicio al Estado ecuatoriado de igual
forma también los interpelantes han
hablado de que sí existía un borrador de
la contraloría que señalaba de
responsabilidades penales en contra de
estos contratos perjudiciales De igual
forma también aseguró tener las pruebas
para responsabilizar políticamente al
presidente de la república Inclusive la
asambleísta ha señalado el tener
Guillermo lasso tendría vinculación en
el asesinato de Rubén elcheres
finalmente qué ha dicho Guillermo lasso
ha dicho que no hay contrato ni arena
firmada que no hay recomendación de
contraloría que no hubo determinación de
responsabilidades por parte de la
contraloría y que no hay testigos
relevantes en este juicio político
Rodrigo bueno Gustavo esto ha sido solo
la primera jornada pero ahora hasta
cuándo puede durar el juicio Y qué se
espera para mañana
Pero ha sido la primera parte debes
tomar en cuenta de que en este debate
que se desarrolla el día de hoy no se
votará por ninguna resolución Pero qué
pasará luego de este debate se estima
inclusive que continuar hasta el día de
mañana finalizado el debate entre los
asambleístas quienes razona en este
momento sus alegatos se estima que será
luego de 72 horas cuando el presidente
de la asamblea nacional Virgilio es aquí
será convoque a una sesión definitiva
sea conocido hasta oficialmente que esta
votación sería el próximo sábado 20 de
mayo pero cuáles podrían ser los
escenarios que esperan al Ecuador bueno
en principio la censura de institución
que es lo que busca este juicio político
y contra el presidente de la república
que no vayan los votos que no se
consigan los votos por el cual el
presidente de República
continuaría con su mandato que haya una
intervención por parte de la corte
constitucional Todo cuenta porque el
presidente de la república ha pedido una
intervención por parte de la corte para
que verifique Cómo ha sido el
seguimiento de juicio político y
finalmente que existe una renunciada
voluntaria por parte del presidente de
la república y quedaría en sucesión del
poder el vicepresidente de borrero a
esta hora Todavía faltan muchos
asambleístas participantes en este
debate de juicio político y finalmente
que el presidente de la república se
adelante y aplique la muerte Cruzada una
causal legal en la Constitución al cual
disolvería la asamblea nacional y
llamaría elecciones generales
anticipadas para
determinar si Cuál va a ser el destino
al Ecuador